ce matin là nous assistons étonné à un
cours du professeur jean marc pastor a
tous ne suffira pas ce que n'a pu leur
éviter c'est de la merde c'est déjà bien
on va commencer avec le prenais mon trou
du cul toi la danseuse la mois à les
toits que d'autres merci 3 aurait
peut-être eu un trou duc trou maintenant
je peux pas et tout cela pourquoi c'est
facile quand ça nrj12 [ __ ] s'écrit en
tags ou merde je marque je vois pas bien
le tableau des six a coiffé très petit
coup du trou je n'arrive pas c'est trop
dur pour moi à merde tu te rends tu es
affaires et tu dégages vas-y gros bâtard
mon travail c'est de comprendre et de
soigner les bouffées de chaleur les
roosli gastrique générés par un
nervosité impactant sur le larynx à
cause d'une dilatation des muqueuses et
du corps spongieux et en d'autres termes
la notation est une doit mener herbe
allez monsieur hors france la dernière
tentative après celle opération alors au
visualiser vos cordes vocales à respirer
maintenant imaginez celle de barry white
et on y va
j'ai mal à ma gauche et mal à ma gorge
j'ai mal à ma gauche et la gorge c'est
la vie la vie c'est la voie la parole
c'est la vie je pousse un coup de gueule
contre magor parce qu elle m'empêche
d'être libre et la liberté c'est la
qualité intrinsèque de l'homme et nerb
site ina meschik zetchi civile
bonjour bienvenue dans la roulotte de
nada nisa alors si vous regardez c'est
que vous êtes dépressif ou au chômage
vous les donne alors j'en profite pour
saluer tous nos téléspectateurs bernard
martin éric et c'est tout voilà
profitez-en pour nous appeler quand si
vous voulez poser des questions et en
organisant ce sera un plaisir d'y
répondre
bonjour mme denise à un jour jean marc
vous êtes décidément toujours au poil a
dit c'est incroyable comme vous avez dit
mono savez ça m'a fait penser à genoux
conduit y est très musclé irréprochable
côté piccoli en tout sept ans premier
téléspectateurs en ligne il s'agit de
philippe ils nous appellent de meulan en
voilà
bonjour fini quel est votre question
voilà je vous appelle car je suis très
inquiet j'ai perdu ma petite chatte
saucisses je voulais savoir si j'ai une
chance de la voir revenir
eh bien écoutez philippe d'avancé désolé
que vous habitiez i'm alone en face
comme un malheur n'arrive jamais seul
vous avez donc en plus perdu votre
petite saucisse ou gros chat je ne sais
plus trop enfin parce que vous savez ça
me rappelle un gondolier très musclé que
j'ai connu avec me convainc ses
homologues ouistiti circus est toujours
bien verte sur saint vallier je peux
continuer cet homme est mort et vous
qu'il était allergique aux poils
à l'entrée le pont tournons nous
invitons donc aux oraux un énoncé c'est
bon je crois que je l'aperçois fausse
alerte
elle est revenue merci aux elle est
revenue battue va bien balancé passe
aussi ce que vous arrivez l'appeler ses
bras bah oui vous savez quand